Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for
the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
July 23rd, uh, 2018. How's it going?
How are you, what do you say there? Um,
before we get going,
I have something to promote.
A old freckles all ringside red face
is going to be at a the next rough and
rowdy event. August 1st
in Youngstown, Ohio.
Legendary, legendary in the
fight game, Youngstown, Ohio.
Um, it's Sunday, August 5th,
2018 at 7:00 PM eastern time.
You can preorder at r n
r four paper view stream.
Um,
you go right to their website,
rough and Rowdy brawl.com r o u g h,
the letter n r o w d
y Brawl B r a w l.com.
Check it out. I was at the
last one. And uh, you know,
it's one of the most favorite things
I've ever done in show business.
It's just a, you know, it's
everything you want to see. You know,
it's a,
it's,
it's conflicting groups of people duking
it out with not a lot of skill and you
just get to sit there and enjoy it.
Um,
I'm thinking this is going to
be a lot of maniacs there. Uh,
as you know, Youngstown
is no joke. All right?
And I can't wait to be there and not
fight anybody like the coward that I am.
Having said that, let me be, uh,
let me live my best life.
Let me be a hero to myself.
Michael's for the second half of
2018 is to be my own personal hero.
Okay.
These fucking social media people.
Have you ever like,
there's nothing, I don't know. I
didn't know where to begin with this.
If I see one more fucking fat,
miserable loser was wearing a tee
shirt that has some sort of self help,
advice to me, like they've reached
the Mecca of peace and happiness.
It's just like, Ooh, is that fucking
tee shirt for yours? Is it for me?
You know,
I just saw this,
this fucking miserable looking person
sitting down in the airport, you know,
tens and tens and tens of fucking pounds
overweight eating shit food with a tee
shirt that says love yourself.
You know what I mean?
And all of this fucking crap now where
you pat people on the back because
they're fucking up their lives, but they
still feel good about, you know what?
I like who I am. I'm not saying
you shouldn't like who you are,
but you got to look at yourself in the
mirror at some point and just be like,
dude, the fuck are we
doing here? You know,
not saying I'm perfect.
I'm not a perfect person,
right? But I'm not, you know, sitting
around here like calling myself a hero,
you know,
based off of all my fucking
short comics,
Hollywood puts pressure
and fuck he did it tonight.
Is that a Hollywood?
Hollywood gives people what they want.
All right?
You fucking constant.
So sick of everybody
blaming this innocent town
we hear in all he would happen
to be some of the, the most,
uh, dependable, loyal, honest you
would be eggs you ever going to meet?
Yeah. I could even get through without
laughing. Whatever. Fuck you this car.
This time we'll give you
whatever the fuck you. Bye. Okay.
And you've been looking at fucking abs
and big tits since the second they had
moving pictures. So I don't want to
fucking hair these fucking assholes,
you know?
Okay.
And I like those other people.
The fucking fat guys with the, uh,
with the tough guy. Shit
on this shirt, you know?
Do I look like I give a shit?
You know, that's no, no,
you don't. Yeah, I would believe that.
You don't give a shit about anything.
All right.
With your fucking fungus.
Riddell toenails while wearing
your little fucking flip flops.
Oh my God. Do you ever see
people there? Their toe nails,
they look like fucking petrified wood and
they're literally walking around just,
you know,
yeah.
I guess living their best life, but making
you look at them. I swear to God, man.
I saw somebody in airport recently
that had these flip flops.
It also had like this toenail flap on it.
Joe Is really excited,
but I hear stomping feet. That
can only mean one. Yeah. Ah, oh.
Hey Buddy,
how you doing?
Said he's in there making a fool
of himself. No running in here.
Come on.
Well,
look how big you get.
Oh, come on. Come on buddy. Do
it. Your mom says, trust me.
I've tried it the other way. It
doesn't work. No, not by, come on.
All right.
The Monday morning podcast has been
briefly interrupted.
Oh, somebody is tired.
Why? By, Oh, you want to say hi. Can we
give her a hug? Hang on again. Any paused.
All right, I'm back. Crisis averted.
The fuck was I talking about
how great people are in
Hollywood? How we are, you know,
there's a couple of bad apples.
I'm not going to lie to you.
There's a few people out here. You know,
I might be one of those people who knows,
you know? Um, anyways,
what was I talking about? Dog
Gone It. Ah, Jesus Christ.
It just interrupted Christ.
It fucked up my whole flow.
I Dunno what I was talking. Who
gives a shit? Right? What do I pit?
Stop and go back and fucking
try and listen to it. Um,
anyways,
I have no idea what I was talking about.
Let me plow ahead here.
As I always do,
I swear to God, this fucking house,
if it's not one thing,
it's another.
Every time I get something
fixed, something else
breaks. You know what I mean?
Okay.
This can't be what owning a house is
like. I just, I had to have bought up,
there's gotta be some
sort of fucking lemon law.
I'm fucking,
it's UN fucking believable.
Well, those people that
have a lawyer on retainer,
that just means a constantly
getting in fucking trouble.
So they're just constantly
paying the fucking guy.
I should have a plumber on retainer.
I know what that means.
What the fuck does that mean? It just
sounds cool. I have a lawyer on retainer.
Okay. Oh my God. Oh my God.
Give me an idea what the fuck my dad does
that has got it.
I still cannot get over the fact that
an adult said that to another adult.
Do you have any idea what
the fuck my dad does?
You know, it's like, it's you like
your there and the other guys there.
You guys are facing off with each other
and then the fuck another du grabs it by
the throat,
throws him down to the ground and
then he stands up and all he has is,
you're fucked. You're fucked.
And I evidently, he walks
away to go get his dad.
The kids in his twenties.
Dad,
what's the matter?
Is that 35 year old across the
street picking on you again son?
Um,
anyways,
I went down to a comic con all freckles
who's done nothing but make fun of comic
con, um, forever.
I went down there on Thursday because,
uh,
Vince and all the guys at better call
Saul were nice enough to ask me to a
mediator, is that the word? Basically
host the panel, the better call Saul,
uh,
to promote the season premiere August
6th on Amc a season four premiere.
And, uh, and after that, the 10 year,
um, breaking bad reunion 10 years
since their first episode debuted,
I would think 2008. And, uh,
I went down there and there was all
these people dressed like superheroes.
Most people are not dressed up,
but there's enough people that
dressed up that it was cool.
And I went down there and I gotta tell
you I've really liked those fucking nerds,
man.
They were really cool people.
I only teased at one time cause I was
saying something that was a spoiler and I
was like, hey spoiler alerts, everybody
saw the last season of better call Saul.
You saw what happened in the last episode
and this dude down front was like,
yeah, I didn't see it.
And I was like, all right,
well a stick a couple of lights
safe senior year cause I,
I have to fucking read
this shit or something like
that. And everybody laughed.
Everybody had a good time with
it. I wasn't sure if, you know,
the self sabotage MV wanted to walk
out and opened with I had doe and you
fucking nerds, but I just didn't want
to bring them back to high school.
I figured I was in their Dojo. I'm going
to be polite. You know what I mean?
Is Fun as it is to do what that fucking
guy on Fox News did that one time when
he went on that show with Barbara
Walters, you know, remember that.
And half the fucking crew
from walked off the stage,
I can't remember anybody's
fucking names anymore. Anyways,
I was down there and I had a great time
and I flew a with my instructor down
there and an our 44.
It's the first time I've flown.
I hadn't flown since the end of
May, you know, it was overseas, uh,
you know, doing gigs and celebrating
my birthday probably far too long,
admittedly. And then the last
week of June, I, you know,
in the beginning of July I had to get
caught up with all the work that I lost.
I missed, I mean, sorry. And, uh,
I flew and a I did all right man,
you know,
a little rusty at first and then it
all fucking came back and I had my best
effin landing
I've ever had as far as uh,
you know,
not having to look at my instruments
too much and just feeling,
just failing at being common one
with the fucking machine there. Uh,
it was getting dark out.
We came back to Burbank and
we will listen to the atus,
which is just the information
did every hour for the airport.
You have to listen to it and
it's some computer voice.
You know, we're in Chicago,
girl driver, a girl, your wire up
here for a measured mark arcade.
So then you get on with Burbank,
tell you like Burbank Tower,
helicopter Blahblahblahblahblah
bulb blew it.
The helicopter had fucking
Hollywood reservoir,
a requested full stop at
Atlantic with information Yankee.
So they know you've got the
latest information. Then
they tell you what to do.
A Dow,
there was a bunch of traffic coming in,
so they told us to hold over old Maaco,
which is his fucking hunk of shit.
Macy's off the one seventies that they're
finally redoing and he just fucking
orbit over there to all the big boys
go in and then they say, you know,
helicopter Blahblahblah cleared for
landing runway eight west of Delta Eight.
So then you just say all that shit back.
So I said all that shit back. I come in,
they got the uh, the fucking
whatever. They go, well you
know those, those fucking,
the power lines there.
Chop your head off.
I flew over the tower like you
supposed to, not over the wires.
And then I was coming in at the right
speed because it was a jet behind me. Um,
but I was a little too high,
so I just banked it really hard using
my gs to make the fucking helicopter
heavier. Don't ask me how physics.
Right. And then it fucking came down.
I was going to come down
with like 600 feet permitted,
which as long as I'm
moving forward is fine.
But as I slowed down and got it down to
300 commercial fucking landing right in
the fucking glide path, right. And the
numbers and Fucking Bang, a left on Delta,
8:00 AM my instructor goes, that's
the best lesson that you've over done.
The becoming one with the helicopter.
And I turned around and my wife's in the
back in her headphones weren't working
and she didn't hear it. And you know
what? I hate to say it. So it was like,
it never happened.
And it was literally sitting there like
a five year old talking to my mom going,
dad, did you hear that? Did
you? And she was like, wow,
you know,
there's a part of me that
actually thinks she did here,
you know,
but to keep me in fucking line to keep me,
keep chasing the fucking cared.
She acted like she didn't hear it.
So anyways, um, moving along,
I want to thank everybody on the cast
of breaking bad and better call Saul for
doing the heavy lifting and telling
the stories and all that. I mean,
I was having like a,
you know,
nightmares about hosting that and meet,
turning into the real version of Chris
Farley. You know that that character,
he would do a Paul Mccartney.
You remember when you and John Lennon,
you guys wrote to the white
album? Uh, yes Chris. Yes, I do.
That was awesome. Like I was worried
that I was going to be doing that.
I'm not going to say there wasn't a couple
of moments of that, but uh, you know,
the whole time I was up there I was like,
why didn't they get Jimmy Kimmel to do
this? That was my first fucking thought.
Cause I remember he did. Um, he did the,
uh, when they had the
final episode in, in La,
they did this thing at the Hollywood
forever cemetery and they showed the,
uh,
the final episodes.
You could sit outside and fucking with
all these other breaking bad fans.
It was really a fucking awesome night.
And Kimmel hosted it
and he did a great job.
So I imagined the reason why he didn't
do it was because he had to host his own
show. And uh, yeah, that
makes sense. All right.
He had the host his talk show tapes at
five and that was going to be from three
to five 30 down in San Diego.
Oh, there we go. Hey, hey, go.
That's why all freckles got
called up from the mine. Ah,
for a cup of coffee,
speak in a cut and called up from the
minors and a cup of coffee and all that.
I'm back into watching the red sox a
very, at least paying attention, man.
I'd started with me trying and like using
listening to baseball as a way to not
flip out and traffic and um,
you know, and just settling in to just
not, I just stopped fighting the city.
Just like, yeah man, this is
going to be a lot of traffic.
There's going to be a lot of people doing
things that I'm not going to like and
I just need to just,
I'm just gonna sit there and watch it
happen and just sort of inch along as I
listened to five innings of a baseball
game and go maybe three quarters of a
mile, that's what I'm going to do.
And that's what I've been doing.
And I just listened to the red sox games
and, um, the Red Sox, I'll tell you too,
they were on fire.
I was worried that the all star
break was going to slow them down.
Date one 10 out of 11. Um, I'm sorry.
They want 11 out of that 10 outlet.
They want 11 out of 12
as right. Cause they went 10
and older than the last one.
And then they won a ripple
of the all star game. I know.
I sound like the fucking rain man.
Then we just took two or three from the
tag is, so we went 13 out of the last 15,
uh, and the Yankees just keep winning
too. Um, but I gotta tell you,
I watched a little bit of the Astros
two them and watching those guys,
I still think they're the team to beat.
Um,
they had Verlander they got
a great picture of staff
and they, they got the bats,
they get the whole fucking thing and they
want it last year and nobody's really
talking about and everybody's
all excited for fucking Yankees,
red sox and uh,
this is what I think.
Alright. Yankees, bullpens,
socks that's going to come
back and bite him in the ass.
And uh,
Chris sale is our guy and
you know, as much as I
love David Price, you know,
he had a really rough outing against
the Yankees in New York and uh,
him curse [inaudible] Dennis Eckersley.
I don't know.
I Dunno that I was like, oh,
that's a hall of fame of man,
you don't curse out a
fucking hall of Famer.
So I'm worried that that
guy's a little, uh, you know,
what, are you a little
shaky between the uh, the,
is there little Odell Beckham there?
Right.
You know, I don't know. I hope
he is because if he isn't,
we've got to beast.
He is a beast.
But I'm just worried that when he went
down to New York and all these people,
it's fucking stupid.
Fuck me kind of imploded.
Rather than being like,
I'm going to ruin that fat man.
Titted singing fucking jackass,
Yankee Fan,
they still do that roll call thing.
It's like Jesus Christ.
I always feel like a musical is
going to break out after that. Um,
yeah, they do have a lot of that
and then they do the YMC a thing.
I mean it's just, you know, and every
time you think that's the worst thing,
then sing sweet Caroline.
It's just,
I don't know what has happened
to both of those franchises.
It's so weird how so
much shit just got nicer.
But people are so much meaner in a way,
you know. Thank you. Go to New York
City, like fucking Yankee stuff.
I went to a game in 1983 there,
the whole family went down there and
it was like taking your fucking Louis
Woodward Day game.
Okay.
And as you got to New York,
there was literally cars just burned out
on those side of the fucking highway.
And I don't mean in the middle of nowhere
on some side road on the side of the
highway,
like burn to the fucking ground.
I remember that was one of the
things when Giuliani got an office,
it was one of the first things he did was
he got those things off of the highway.
That was such a bad
fucking look for New York.
Or maybe it was a good look because it
was warning terror at terrorist tourists
about what they were about to
experience. But, um, I don't know.
Everybody was getting Giuliani credit.
Who is the head,
the chief of police there that he fired
along the way so he'd get all the credit.
Oh, Bill, do you always
have to be a con? Yeah, I to
Julie,
Aye.
Chief of Foley's fired.
Let's see what this guys come on.
Come on.
Slow Internet ease bill burry as
the slowest Internet in Los Angeles.
Yeah,
it's still fucking gone.
Um, and now I'm in,
I like, I don't even know. I don't
even know, like a sporting event.
There used to always be
like an element of, hey,
keep your head on a fucking
swivel and Jesus Christ,
you have no idea what you're going to see.
Like people acted like fucking animals.
There was fights in the stands
and all that type of shit.
I'm not saying obviously that
I wanted to go back to that,
but somewhere along the line like it just
became like, it's like, it's just weird.
It's like you go into a Chucky cheese,
um,
it's still loading by the way.
Still loading.
That's probably because I take the
Giuliani and something negative. That's,
that's my guess. I'm going to go with
the whole conspiracy theory here. Um,
yeah. Anyways, I dunno if you
go to sporting events now,
it's like every time
there's a stoppage of play,
then something happens up
on the fucking flat screen.
Everybody just stares at it
with their mouth hanging open.
And I really think that
that's like this thing.
So people like don't fight
and behaved themselves.
You know,
you know,
you get that camera on your flat screen
TV and all those fucking nerds at the
best buy sit there watching you jerking
off to the fucking Charlie's angels on
me TV, whatever you're
doing. Right. But you know,
in between those times when they waiting
for you to fuck your wife or whatever
those fucking nerd perverts I doing
down there that for some reason it's not
fucking enforced.
You know what I mean?
You got all this fucking
me too shit happening.
And meanwhile these fucking nerds
are watching you in your living room.
It's, I'm not making this shit up.
Like they'd gotten busted doing it.
I don't know why they admitted to it.
They were like, are you doing that?
They're like, oh yeah, no, we're
not gonna say we're not. Um,
I dunno anyways. Yeah. And
they just sit there fucking,
okay.
I mean, if you're gonna, if you're
gonna go after the, the pervert.
Okay. Giuliani renews ties
with police chief. He to
in 1995 William Jay Brandon
left in New York City,
New York City police commissioner with
Mayor Rudolph Giuliani. The two men.
Okay. Yeah, that's the guy. From
what I've heard. Now granted,
this might have been
people that hated Giuliani,
which God knows a lot of people do.
MMM.
This might be bullshit, but I don't
know what it was this coming from.
This is the New York Times. All right,
so they hate Giuliani. All right.
The two men, Rudolph Giuliani and
his former police commissioner,
William Jay Brandon had not
spoken to each other in 10 years.
This is from 10 years ago.
This was written when they had crossed
paths as social gambling exchanged little
more than IC nods,
but time,
tragedy and presidential campaign
has started to change all of that.
Uh, all right. I don't even,
what the fuck it is. I think that was
the guy that really turned it around.
That started on the road where
it's now like, it's weird.
It's like,
uh,
my father in law said and came down and
he was standing in Brooklyn cause she,
wow, this is like a, it's
like a theme park, you know,
it's like people riding bicycles
along the river and all this stuff.
It's sort of like a, uh, it's
sort of like if you have money,
yeah,
it's become this utopia
or something. I Dunno.
When does the pendulum swing back?
That's what I want to know. Jesus Christ.
Because I imagine
in the 70s when New York
almost went bankrupt,
there was a bunch of old people got map.
But when this place was a dre bled,
what was that grandma back when white
swirl only allowed to play baseball back
when Hitler was walking the earth.
Yeah.
Well, I suppose shows change
weren't right, but, uh,
you could leave your door unlocked.
Um,
that is the thing.
Then anytime you say good old days,
there's always some fucked
up shit going on. Right.
Okay.
Yeah. Bill. Yeah. That, that really
wasn't anything deep. I didn't say.
Okay.
All right.
So what been doing lately?
A Speyside not boozing
tell you right now. All
fucking uh, or freckles. He,
I haven't drank all this month. It's
been great, man. It's really been great.
I'm still fucking tired though. I
haven't a kid. You still tired? But, um,
I'm but like,
I remember one day waking up when I was
on the road anticipating a hangover and
not having one and I was like, wow,
that's pretty awesome. You know,
I'm trying to eat. Well, they're
going to talking to a nutritionist,
you know what I'm saying?
I got to get the answers to the test here
rather than listening to fucking every
Tom, Dick and Harry, you
know, Dean del Ray knows what
the fuck he's talking about,
but I'm getting bored with the Diet.
I got to add up the shit and, uh,
want to add some vegan
meals, you know, you know,
not because I want to go
vegan just because I know if
you eat them then you know,
your stomach is flatter. Just give
my body a break from, you know,
beef Bourguignon Skirt steaks
and all of that shit. You know.
Um, I saw this thing, the
other dance, like he just,
you don't even know who to fuck to
belief. Like, one of the things, you know,
when you look at Vegetarians and you
look at Vegan people, uh, you know,
this is an astounding level of fleshy
fat people that don't eat meat,
you know what I mean?
And they'll eat French fries because
it's made from potatoes and they're a
vegetarian, but it's fried.
And they'll say, you know,
potatoes on good fee anyways,
as far as I know, I'm, man,
I shouldn't even say that.
I don't want to be all opera here and
get people to stop eating potatoes.
And then the whole fucking potato farm
farming industry sues me here at the
Monday morning podcast.
Um,
okay.
But there's just a lot,
you know,
the like fucking just all
carbohydrates and shit. Um,
and they just stay away from me. Uh,
I think a lot of people love animals,
but they hate reading is what I've sort
of learned from looking at Vegetarians
and Vegan people, you know,
so they don't eat meat,
but then they don't really know
what the fuck it is they're doing.
But the people that do take
the time to do it, right?
Like nobody who lived in this house
for a hundred fucking years, evidentaly
took the time to do something.
Right. I didn't do that.
And it's called it fucking
friend of fix it, didn't it?
Okay,
fuck it. A permit. Fuck
it. Somebody licensed.
Fuck all of that.
What did they do?
They just fucking lived here. They
had a problem. They asked a friend.
And I think a lot of vegans
and vegetarians do that.
They fucking talk to
people rather than reading.
And that's what I do because it's easier.
It's easier than sitting down and
actually doing the fucking work. So,
you know, I see that, you know,
like can anybody if
Gundy your fucking head,
can anybody tell you whether
having an egg is good for you?
A bad at this point eggs had been good,
bad,
good.
And now they're starting to be bad again.
While people who was saying
that good a fucking, you know,
they too can have this like the
rubber match, the rubber game,
whatever the fuck it's called.
Right. Um, so I'm going to,
I'm going to talk to a nutritionist
and I'm gonna, I'm gonna, you know,
try to read up on it, but
it's, it's really dry. And
if you actually look up shit,
okay.
On becoming a vegetarian or
eating a little like that,
like a Vegan or something,
it's just Hatfields and McCoys and
is between the fucking meat eaters to
carnivores and the vegetarian people.
And there's a lot of money at stake,
no pun intended. Sorry about that. Um,
so I think like the big farming cattle,
fucking people,
you know,
they're trying to have all this shit
come up first and then all the the tree
hugger and like, hey man, like you know,
trees are alive man.
Those fucking people are trying to
say that, you know, eating meat is,
is like, like I saw this thing, right?
What they were saying that this guy
was trying to say that like animals get
protein from eating plants and when you
eat an animal it's an indirect protein
because she should just gone directly
to the plant and it's like both then
explain tigers and they're fucking,
you know,
Mister Universe physiques
as far as I know,
which is, I don't know shit.
So I should shut up right now.
And Google what a Tiger Z.
Yeah.
What do tigers eat?
Okay.
Meet only when they're
always in a bad mood.
I can't even take a shit Siberian.
The species died.
Ordinary consists about 50% wild boar
meat. Doesn't that sound delicious?
If they cannot get their paws on some
wild boar, they've been known to eat elk,
deer in legs. They're like, well,
what do we fucking with me for a man?
I didn't do nothing.
And sometimes even bears.
Oh my God. What size? Jesus Christ.
That's a big thing in Asia.
Putting like a bear and a tiger and
a fucking cage and just filming it.
If large sources of meat
are not readily available,
Siberian tigers will eat rabbits,
fish and any rodents they can get to.
Let's see.
Okay,
well there's no meat in that due to,
and that's the first thing I saw.
Do Tigers
plants.
What do tigers eat? Siberia and the
species side consistent. Still this.
Okay.
Uh,
tiger's diet,
eating tigers eat a variety of prey
ranging in size from termites to elephant
calves. All that would break my heart to
see a baby elephant get killed. However,
an integral component of the
Diet, Laura, are large body,
pray weighing 45 pounds
or larger such as Moose d.
What do we fucking mean? Moose and
bear, where the fuck are those things?
I thought they were the most were
only over here. Deer species,
pigs, cows, horses, buffaloes and goats.
Yeah. Well, they have a different
digestive system of evidently,
cause if you just fucking
hate that, that's they're
basically on the Atkins Diet,
right?
Yeah.
He's much fucking bacon as you want
taiga is looking at you like yeah,
I realize that. I realize
that. Um, so anyways,
I'm going to try to
fucking, uh, I don't know.
I'm going to talk to a nutritionist,
somebody who read all the shit that I'm
supposed to read and maybe try to get
them to tell me some, a pill. And you
really gonna buy books on nutrition.
Like you're going to fucking read them.
Do they have a lot of pictures?
Um,
anyways,
I should probably read some advertising.
I don't feel like fucking doing that.
Hey, I'm almost like
halfway through this season,
six of a 77 sunset strip.
Um, and evidently see, I, as I said,
season six, you gotta watch it.
It's on at 4:00 AM on me TV.
Just take the fucking thing.
How about getting more people to watch
it because I'm worried because I found
out that they started broadcasting all
the episodes back in November and I
missed the first five seasons.
And we're getting towards the end here
of season six because they didn't do a
full season. They got canceled like
three quarters of the way through. Um,
and I'd like to see the original ones
because I'd like to see what La look back
then. You know, hopefully
they do some exterior's,
although I know most of it
was formed on the back lot,
filmed on the back lot in Warner brothers.
Um,
but,
uh,
I'm loving this season so I'm worried
that the other one is going to be a little
hokey because I guess a lot of people
didn't like season six. First of all,
they fired the whole fucking
cast as a bad shoot. Sorry.
Um,
but I also didn't realize that they made
Efram Zimbalist jr his character a lot
more surly and uh,
but I'm loving them.
So now I'm worried that I saw the season
six first and if I go back and look at
the others, and I'm not going to like it
the show the same way the other people,
cause I get, you just get used
to how the guy behaves, you know.
But some of the lines, man, some of
the shit that people say on there,
here's some ex in like, you
know, women are, are, are uh,
are talking about how behave around them.
You know,
like in some of the shit that they
say, it's like Jesus Christ. I mean,
I'm sure that guy's out there,
but what the fuck, you know,
sunset season six of
[inaudible] 77 sunset strip day.
It sounds like what some of these women
are describing is some of the shit I
heard them say guys saying to
women on that show pipe down,
shut up.
Not to mention after that from tries to
bang his fucking secretary tried to look
up or dress one ups. I'm just sitting
there and this guy would get me too.
It's so fucking fast. It have his
full head of hair spinning. Right.
And then my favorite one
ever favorite one ever,
as I mentioned on another
podcast is when he sat down in
this episode with the actor that ended
up playing the professor or Gilligan's
island. Sorry, I'm talking
through yawns right now.
Yeah,
the accident played the professor
in Gilligan's island. And the,
the guy was three drinks in
and AV firms meeting him.
It's the middle of the day and
the guy orders his fourth drink
and a afro goes, you got a pretty active
elbow for lunchtime. You on the sauce.
Okay.
That is the one thing also
that I love about that show.
It makes you feel better about
drinking and smoking cause uh,
that from Zimbalist almost made 90
and there's barely a scene.
He's not smoking a cigarette
and he's really smoking it too.
And that's just on the tape that they use.
So who knows?
I'm all right with that.
Should it read a little bit of
advertising? Yeah. Why don't I do that?
77 sunset strip.
Uh Oh Jesus.
Here we go. There's somebody
new mint, mobile, mobile.
I'm going, wow. Ah,
the big and big wireless stands
for a lot of things. Big Contracts,
big bills and big fees like a t and
t's new $800 million administration fee
increase. Wow. They're just
making up phase now. I know.
I love when they do that because they
think that you don't have a choice.
What big wireless doesn't want
you to know that there's a what?
There's that there's a way out to cut
your wireless bill down to just 15 bucks a
month.
Introducing meant mobile,
the game changing company that's taking
everything wrong with big wireless and
making it right.
Okay,
well let's hope they stay that way.
Let's hope they don't put the other
guys out of the business and then they
become the devil because that's
usually what happens. But right now,
mid mobile mobile,
deep,
deep is are the good guys meant.
Mobile makes it so easy to
cut your wireless bill down
to just 15 bucks a month.
The what are you allowed one texts?
How can you do that?
Use Your own phone with
any mint mobile plan.
You can keep your old number along
with all your existing contacts.
Choose between two five or 10 GBS is
like gigabytes or four g LTE plans.
No more paying for unlimited
data that you'll never use.
Every plan comes with unlimited talk
and text. We'll answers that question
so you could safely annoy
your friends and loved ones.
And if you're not 100% satisfied,
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
with their seven day money back guarantee
outfox your old wireless bill and start
saving with mint mobile. Keep be booming.
Call to action to get your new wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month plus free
shipping on your Mint Mobiles Sim card.
Go to mint mobile.com/burr that's meant
mobile.com/berg cut your wireless bill,
the 15 bucks a month and get free
shipping on your Mint Mobile Sim
card@meantmobiledotcommintmobile.com slash
bar
somebody please try that out and
let me know how their services,
cause that's a hell of a fucking price.
And I can tell you I'm with
Verizon and these fucking cunts.
My bill always ends up going up
to like 300 bucks for no reason.
And then I'm like, why is it
300 bucks? Oh an actual year.
That year and a half I'm like, damn,
this dude institute. Which way,
but bug can do that now.
It's only 180
they know
and then it fucking goes back up again.
I pay so much money for fucking
cell phone and fucking direct TV.
You know someone who was telling me if
you just call up direct TV or something,
you'd just tell him you're
going to fucking get rid
of it. I'm like, all right.
All right. All right. It's not 150 bucks.
It's 45 cause I think they're just
losing it with the, the cord cutters.
Um, hotel tonight. Oh
Jesus should be civil.
That fucking saxophone music from the
1950s every time a woman came onto screen.
Hotel tonight is the Goto APP for
booking great deals at great hotels.
Unlike other hotel booking sites,
hotel tonight doesn't have long,
endless lists of a zillion hotel choices.
Instead,
hotel tonight shows you only the best
deals at the best hotels bed bug free.
They partner with top rated hotels
to help them fill their unsold rooms,
which is how you get such great deals.
And even though the name is hotel tonight,
it's not just for tonight. You can
book tonight, tomorrow or beyond.
It's the perfect. It's perfect for
planners as well as procrastinators.
You could book spontaneous weekends,
three day getaway stay cases, road trips,
business shift. You could book a hotel
just so you can use the fucking pool.
Download the hotel app today to get great
deals at the hotel you actually want
to stay in and with the Promo
Code. [inaudible] B. U. R.
R you can get 25 off your first
eligible booking hotel tonight. Tonight,
tonight, Promo Code Burr. I got
some cool advertising here now. Huh?
Cheap fucking sell service hotel tonight.
You know you want to look your best
when you're enjoying both of those
advantages, right? Well, I got the
thing for your dollar. Shave clubs,
plural. Dollar Shave Club
delivers everything you need
to look, feel and smell.
Your Best Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to get ready in the bathroom.
Any particular product that you have
fallen in love with outside of the razor
and why? Oh, I guess that's for me,
I just love the idea of the one
wipe charity. I've never gotten any.
How about some free samples. You
Bastards Dollar Shave Club. Yes.
That dollar shave club delivers
everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best. You name
it, shampoo check conditioner. Got It.
Bodywash shut your mouth. Toothpaste,
hair, Judge Gel, even a wipe.
That will leave your tush
feeling Tingley clean.
Evidently I'm a big fan of their amber
and lavender calming body cleanser.
I would love to try that
second. My wife goes, honey,
I'll just wipe it on top
of my head coming dear.
Never smelled anything like
it for just five bucks.
You can get their daily essential status.
Said it comes with body cleanser,
one wipe Chari.
They're amazing,
but wipes. They're world's famous
shave butter and their best razor.
This six blade executive.
Keep the blades coming for a few bucks
a month and add in shampoo, toothpaste,
or anything else you
need for the bathroom.
Check it all out@dollarshaveclub.com
slash [inaudible] that's dollar shave
club.com/ [inaudible] all right,
and lastly, but not leastly.
I'm not trying to cause any
advertiser real enemies here. It.
stamps.com everybody,
the u s postal service is an
important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access
all the amazing services of the post
office.
stamps.com never closes right like
that who was legs up to Street d print
postage for letters or
packages at your convenience.
24 seven print postage for any class,
a meal right from your own computer,
the exact amount of postage every time.
Never underpay or overpay again.
stamps.com saves you time and money
which you can use to grow your business.
Buy and print official US postage
for any letter, any package,
any class of mail using your own computer
and they'll send you a digital scale.
Automatically calculates exact postage,
stamps.com believe and help you decide
the best class of mail based on your
needs. No need to lease an expensive
postage meter and there are no long term
commitments.
I use stamps com to send out
all of my posters.
Speaking of which my limited edition
that you can only get at my shows,
which I did not have in Minneapolis
and Detroit. Unfortunately,
because the ones I got were
the leftover ones from Dublin.
And by the time they got here,
they were all fucked up.
But I'm going to have them in Houston
and Dallas and I use stamps.com to send
them out.
I'm a moron if I can figure out how to
use this scale and get some postage.
So can you,
and right now you too can
enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
I've got the hiccups.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthewholepageandtypeinbirththatstamps.com
enter
burpee.
You are are. Hey, by the
way, you know what? I got a,
I got an email from a Darren king,
credible drummer.
Uh,
one of the best drummers I've
ever seen to be honest with you.
And I had no idea that he
could sing and play guitar,
but he did a cover of Richie. Uh, Oh my
God, I'm a saber. Is it Richie havens?
They make sure I have this right.
Yeah.
Uh, yeah. Let me, yes, I was correct.
Richie havens does a song
called freedom and um,
he did a cover version of that that
then goes into something else that is
fucking incredible.
Ah,
I tweeted out the video and we'll
have a link to it on the podcast. Um,
Jesus Christ,
you know,
I like watching how talented that guy is.
I don't even know what the fuck I'm even
doing in this businessman. Incredible,
incredible monster
talent. Uh, check it out.
And I heard he has a solo album coming up.
People were alluding to it.
I hope he does.
If he does,
we are going to promote it here and
I hope you guys buy it because, uh,
he is the real deal. Um, all
right, let's check out some,
uh, am I going to read
some stories? You know,
you know what I'm actually going to do.
I actually came across this foot.
Could think it says news is bad for you.
Okay. This is from something
the guardian.com says,
news is bad for you and giving up reading
it will make you happier. All right,
now I'll tell you right now, I didn't
need this fucking article to tell me this.
I just realized it. I figured it out after
I went down a rabbit hole of fucking,
uh,
you know, conspiracy theory,
you guys remember that?
People listen to the podcast 10 years
ago. I mean, I was fucking, I was, yeah,
I was mystic, you know,
chem trail guy, you know,
how's that guy saying you got to shut
down the Federal Reserve and I had no
solution to do like what would what
you would do after that, you know,
I'm sure people that are well read
on it had the solution, but I didn't.
So I was just walking around freaking
people out. I was a cunt basically.
Um, so anyways, it says
news is bad for your house.
So I just stopped watching the shit.
All right.
I'm just banking on the,
that there's going to be some smart
people with a good heart that,
that are,
that are going to lead us out of this
fucking mess because I don't have any
solutions. All right? I go on stage,
I jump around like a monkey and I
make you laugh. Okay, that's my lane.
And it's a rock used to say, no,
you roll and shut your mouth.
So I'm staying over there. I
tried to watch the news, I try,
I can't, you know, it's the weirdest
thing going from Obama to Trump,
go from Obama where all they did was
lick his balls for eight years and then
they go to Trump and it's just like,
all they do is shit on the
guy the entire fucking time.
And they're both kind of doing,
you know what? The foreign policy,
the same fucking shit, although I
don't, Trump is like a fucking lunatic.
You know what I mean?
I, you know, I heard,
I was just in the Howard stern show
and he went on this fucking rant about
Russia. It W it was just not talking about
the fucking people just talking about,
you know, uh, of laddy
daddy over there. He goes,
I'm sick of people fucking talking about
Russia, you know, like, like the dead,
not that bad. He's like, dude, they
fucking, you know, they kill gay people.
They kill reporters just for having
a difference of opinion and the,
and he's right. He's fucking right. Um,
I dunno, I once that his, his,
his fucking wife wore that coat when he
was going to go visit those kids that,
that she was going to go visit those
kids that they had stuck in cages and she
wore a jacket that said, I don't really
care to you and then turn it. Oh.
Then had to do with fake news.
It's just like,
it's literally like listening to a
toddler lie and I, God bless you,
if you could still watch that and try
and stay politically active because I
don't know it, it's, it's
just too fucking depressing.
I can't fucking deal with it.
So I choose not to watch.
And the last presidency, you
know, I just, I just, it was,
I couldn't fucking, yeah. You know,
I had hope and then I was just like, oh,
this is going to be more of the same. Oh,
bankers don't go to jail.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Insurance companies could do whatever
they, whatever they fucking want. And uh,
yeah.
We're not going to
constructively criticize our
foreign policy and we're just
going to stay the fucking chorus and
shut down the government every fucking
August for a week. And our solution
is always going to be to say, well,
what if we raised the
debt? Right? You know,
and then meanwhile,
everything that his wife did was just
considered like angelic and it's just was
the whole fucking thing was annoying.
That was like when he was in office
was like watching a fucking award show.
Everybody's just walking around,
blowing each other,
talking about how fucking
brilliant they are. And then this,
we went from an awards show
to a fucking train wreck.
I honestly don't know how people
have the stomach to pay attention.
Like you're a, you're a whole other level
tough mentally than I am. So anyways,
his, his, his whole
fucking article here says,
news is bad for you and giving up reading
it will make you happier. All right.
In the past few decades,
the fortunate,
fortunate among us have recognize the
hazards of living with an over abundance
of food, parentheses,
obesity, and diabetes.
And having started to change and
have started to change your diet,
but most of us do not yet understand that
news is to the mind which sugar is to
the body.
News is easy to digest.
The media feeds a small bites of
trivial matter tidbits that don't really
concern our lives and
don't require thinking.
That's why we experience
almost no saturation.
Unlike reading a book or a long magazine
articles which require thinking we can
swallow limitless
quantities of news flashes,
which are bright colored
candies for the mind.
Today we have reached the same point
in relation to the information that we
faced 20 years ago in regard to food.
We're beginning to recognize
how toxic news can be.
I agree with all of this, but everybody
can't stop paying attention or else,
you know, somebody has to pay attention,
right? Somebody's gotta be like getting,
just can't put it on cruise control.
So I don't know if I hundred
percent agree with this,
I just know I'm not going to be the
Gandy that leads us out of this,
you know? So as long as I
know that, I mean I will,
abuse can be content to listen
to Howard in the morning.
And then I listened to
fucking baseball at night.
That's what the fuck I do. I don't
pretend to know things. All right.
News misleads all my God. Wow.
Take the following the event.
A car drives over a bridge and
the bridge collapses. What does,
what does the news media focus on the car,
the person in the car where he came from,
where he planned to go,
how he was he transitioning,
how they didn't say that,
how we experienced the crash
parentheses if he survived.
But that is all irrelevant.
What's relevant?
The structural stability of the bridge.
That's the underlying risks that has
been Larkey and could lurk and other
bridges.
All they get to that after
they go painstakingly
through the horror of the end
of that man's life or life
altering injuries and then
they get to his family and
they're all crying and all
of that shit. Um, you know,
as much as a moron, as as I am, I
always turn that shit off. You know,
like out here we had a hostage
situation at a trader Joe's and um,
the people I was with were just watching
it and watching and watching it.
It's like, like, just out of curiosity,
what are you going to do with this guy
just runs out in such shooting people in
the fucking head. Like,
you want to watch this?
These people in the store
are fucking terrified.
This is the worst fucking
moment of their life. All right?
The news eventually is going to tell you
what happened and they're going to give
you an edited version so you don't have
to see people's brains getting blown out,
you know? And why, you know,
they literally had like the
were crying and a lot of shit.
And then I found on the end, you
know, some poor woman died. It was,
it's fucking terrible.
The one way I'm just going to sit at home
watching it for hours, ordering food,
you know, going online. Are they
tweeting from there or what's going on?
Then all these fucking
assholes on Youtube,
a youtube on Twitter
or these social media.
If you're going to go on and say the
obvious, oh my God, this is so sad.
I'm like freaking out right now. I love
that. Oh, is that what you're doing?
Are you freaking out? Or
the safety? Your own home.
Why don't you make this about yourself?
You'll fuck oh Jesus. Social media,
but is people's a lot of shit that says
that's depressing too. But you know what?
Podcasts actually feed the soul.
Believe I'm part of the problem.
News misleads bill Burmis leads. Uh,
anyways, plowing ahead. We
are not rational enough to
be exposed to the press.
Is he this guy saying we're all dumb?
Watching an airplane crash on television
is going to change your attitude toward
that risk regardless of
its real probability.
If you think you can compensate with
the strength of your own inner con
contemplation,
you are wrong.
I think the subtext of this is you dumb
fuck bankers and economist who have
powerful incentives to compensate for
news born hazards have shown that they
could not the only solution cut yourself
off from the news consumption entirely.
News is irrelevant of the approximately
10,000 new stories you have read in the
last 12 months.
Name one that because you consumed it
allowed you to make a better decision
about the serious matter affecting your
life, your career and your business. Well,
I would say anything
about the environment.
You know Jesus had skies
chip off the old block here,
paint with a broad brush.
The point is the consumption
of news is irrelevant to you,
but people find it very difficult
to recognize what's relevant.
It's much easier to recognize what's new.
All right,
I think we get the point here.
I news has no explanatory power news
items or bubbles popping on the surface of
a deeper world. Ooh, that's
deep. That sounds like a
fucking progressive rock band.
Like a line in the song.
Okay.
I'm in [inaudible] seven four I imagine
will accumulate facts that help you
understand the world. Sadly, no,
the relationship is inverted.
The important stories are non stories.
I would agree with that slow,
powerful movement that developed below
journalists radar but have a transforming
effect.
The more news factoids you digest,
the less of the big picture you
will understand. Well, maybe this,
why everybody's yelling at each other.
News is toxic to your body. This is,
I'll just read the headlines here.
News increases cognitive errors.
News inhibits thinking.
News works like a drug.
News waste time and news makes us passive.
Well that worked with me.
News kills creativity. Uh, well
there you go. Jesus Christ.
That's pretty negative, Huh?
Let's get to some positive shit.
I gotta I gotta fucking note from
a possible visit to dove, Ron,
Vic brava. Roves nick though, Bro,
leave Croatia my friend.
Uh,
while you're checking where the
hell I'm contacting you from, uh,
let me jump you with invitation.
Invitation to my country. Slash. City.
I run brewery and we are in debt at the
moment. So don't expect this is money.
Interesting invitation.
This is opportunity for you to check
out crazy side of Buckland's and getting
hours and hours of future material.
By the way, you're funny. Well,
thank you sir.
Uh,
that read like a fucking ransom note from
eastern Europe and I would be lying to
you if I wasn't a little
afraid to go to your bar.
I need a couple of those in there.
You know,
while you're checking where I got
the hell I'm contacted you from,
let me jump in with an invitation
that'd be jumping with invitation.
Uh, you, you fucking
talk like Ivan Drago. Um,
listen buddy,
I'm going to try and get as close to
dumb Bruv nick as they possibly can.
I wish your bar was making more money.
Uh,
and I'd love to go in there and help
you out with your fucking monthly rent.
Buy Booze and my face off,
but I don't, I can tell you,
I don't think I'm going to make it there.
Uh,
Eastern European toward Jesus Christ.
This is all I'm getting.
This is all east eastern Europe
where Eastern European tour.
Dear Billy Ball Burger. Oh, come on now.
When I was feeling I was
feeling good about myself, uh,
I'm a huge fan of your comedy and F is
for family is my favorite thing on next
flicks. Well, thank you
very much. Therefore,
I am very excited that you're
thinking of visiting Prague,
Czech Republic comedy scene in
Prague is pretty much nonexistent.
Oh geesh. So I'm sure you would
kill with your knock knock jokes.
Um,
if you are interested,
pint of beer cost between
one to $2 and it's delicious.
He also have to try
traditional alcohol drink
Slivovo vis.
It's made from distilled plums
and has about 51% of alcohol.
Okay.
I'm in.
You could visit the Czech hockey hall
of fame or you could go to cr Mayor Yara
placed some second division hockey.
Oh, that would be cool. Shit,
I'm probably only going
to be there for a night.
I think this is going to be a
a bunch of one nighters here.
A while back you mentioned you saw the
movie anthropoid about a checklist of Aki
and paratroopers assassinating
high ranking German Nazi official.
I love that movie. The movie ends
with the final shootout in the church.
You can actually go to the crips of the
church and see the bullet holes from the
incident.
I'm fucking doing that.
IOP decide to come and share your
Merkin wisdom with us savages.
Thanks. And Go make love to your
lovely wife. Oh, thank you. Bless you.
Go Fuck your wife. You fucking read
it. It prick eastern European toy.
Hey Bill.
I've just wanted to say that I know a
lot of people waiting for you to come to
Poland.
Oh Great.
I guess your agents already figured out
that Warsaw seems the most logical place
to do your show as it's the biggest
city in the capitol and it's located
somewhere in the middle of the country.
So most of the people from outside Warsaw
like me will be able to come and see
you live. I'm 100% sure you'll
sell out all of the tickets.
Plus Warsaw is a great place to visit
because of its history and of course all
the cool stuff going on there.
I guess people from the states think
you'll see white bears and trams and horse
drawn carts on the street. But that's
not the case. I didn't think that.
I just thought I'd see four people trying
to screw in a light bulb. Ah, sorry.
Just like everywhere else. We've got
hipsters and Starbucks, moderately fat,
lazy fucks in shopping malls and generally
people wasting their lives on social
media. Yeah, yeah. That's, that's
a reoccurring thing. Anyway,
my friends and I can't wait for your
show. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Yeah.
Everybody's staring at their phones is
a big thing and I do that all the time.
Uh, persistent cold. You
may have walking pneumonia,
go see a doctor when you get
back to la. I need a doctor. So
soft tires and Nazi symbolism. I
love this guy. This guy is just,
he's just doing the whole gamut,
isn't it? Um, running the gamut. Hey,
let's look that up.
Let's see what the fuck that means.
How did that expression come about?
All right.
Run the gamut.
Origin meaning the entire range.
The word Gamet traces its origins to the
Middle Ages in a system for designating
musical notes around the turn
of the second millennium.
The fuck you mean the second millennium?
I thought this was the second
millennium. 2000, right?
Is it a millennium? A thousand years.
I'm an evil monk. Developed a system.
Jesus.
Bill.
Yeah.
I, you know, just gets to the
point like I try to be informed.
Okay,
I see the second you're going
to bring up a fucking monk.
Around the turn of the second millennium,
Guido of our Arizona,
a medieval monk
developed a system of Psalm Ization.
I designating musical
notes by syllable names.
While today we are familiar with
the song syllables, doe ray, me Fa.
So La ti back in Guido's time,
he died in 10 50.
They had a hex tonic scales six note
and he used the symbol earth's re me FA,
Sol and La
and La,
the represented the lowest
note [inaudible] La and ah,
I can't get this white
drums and tell jokes. Uh,
ut represents the lowest tone
recognized in music theory at that time.
The second g below middle c.
What the fuck?
I don't give a fuck about what you say.
What is the gamut? The range of notes.
Okay. Building on this denotation
destination. I don't know.
Gammon eventually came to mean
the whole musical scale. Oh,
so you're running the whole fucking
scale. Okay. Jesus Christ. All right.
Hey Bill, soft tires and Nazi
symbolism by the way. Hey Bill,
I think I can answer both of your
questions from Thursdays podcast.
I'm in law school and a motor
sport fanatic. So the questions,
these questions are right
in my wheelhouse. All right.
What did you were in law school? What?
So you know about Nazi symbolism?
Do you prosecute hate crimes?
I hope a number one.
Why the soft tires and Moto
GP? Uh, principally you,
you're right. I know at the tires to
grade towards the end of the race.
So it makes sense to use harder
ones to get consistent performance.
Especially now that's slightly sliding.
The bike is the quickest
way around the track.
How the fuck you learn
how to do that is crazy.
Yeah.
I mean I've seen people do that in
cars, you know, drifting, but you know,
you're on four wheels.
Like the level of balance at scale,
they'll be ability become
one with the machine.
It's judge other jewelers oleds
are work of art and Germany.
Lorenzo used a soft front tire
while mark is took the hard one. Uh,
for the rears.
Lorenzo was on a medium tire and Marquez
on the soft Marquez is a special driver
and tends to get a better feeling
for the bike with a hard tire.
The sidewalls simp simply
don't wobble around too much.
Lorenzo's bet was to use the
superior pace of the soft tire,
more grip to build enough of an advantage
to win. This is fascinating. Marquez,
meanwhile expected a tight field and
wanting to nurses tires while keeping with
the pack.
Thus having enough tire left for the
last lab and a final attack for a wind,
which is exactly what he did.
Simply put,
the drivers have to decide between
an early pace advantage and therefore
superior track position was soft tires
and the consistency of the hards add,
add changing conditions,
different writing styles and bikes to
that and you'll see how hard it is to pick
up a winning package.
Well,
yeah,
my thing is,
is there a way for him to know what
Mark Marquez is going to be running
considering he's the best writer
out there? As far as I can tell,
no disrespect to Jorge Lorenzo. I know
he's one of the couple of times, but um,
the championship, I believe
he's won two of them. Um,
no matter what tire you're going to have,
you're not going to open up this like,
okay,
insurmountable lead.
So I just think eventually that soft tire
is going to fucking wear out and then
mark has his behind.
He's going to overtake you and then he
then can ride hard for the first time in
the race.
Okay.
He'd beat the shit out of those tires,
but by the time they get fucked up,
the race is going to be over
before that happens. I Dunno.
But thanks for that. That is, that
is fastened cause everybody's lives.
You Watch racy, she's bunk people
driving around John Brown track,
driving around in circles, stock car
racing. You're like, do you need to know?
Go turn left. Um, yeah, that's
all you need to know. Bandit,
Nazi symbolism. Um, I'm enrolled
in one of the best schools.
I love how people are too
dumb to understand racing
and then they sit there and
they shit on it.
Uh,
I'm enrolled in one of the
best law schools in Germany
over here displaying Nazi
symbolism is punishable with up to five
years in prison in the context of the
whole legal system.
It's quite an unusual article of the law.
Usually this is amazing. So he, cause
cause you're a lawyer in Germany,
usually the political background of an
opinion is irrelevant to the criminal
repercussions to avoid discrimination.
Usually objective factors are
used instead of political ones.
It was discussed whether it banning and
punishing Nazi sympathetics displays his
constitutional. It is an infringement
on the freedom of speech. Yes it is.
Um, and it also lets you
know who the Nazis, uh,
the one argument that
won in court was this,
this was the historic significance in
Germany. Uh, the constitution with,
by the way, I'm loving all these,
these letters from around the world.
This is fucking incredible. If I
could just get some women to write it.
I know I'm off putting lays,
but you know,
that kind of gives you an
opportunity to put me in my place,
which is one of my favorite things.
You hear when my wife saw here,
she shits all over me. I love
it. Giggling like a schoolgirl.
The constitution was put into place in
1949 while most cities still look like
downtown Baghdad circle 2004 a and when
the ovens of Auswitch had just cooled
down, Jesus, uh,
the content of the constitution is an
answer to all the shit that went down
between 1933 in 1945.
Yeah,
Pres. Most those lunatics
died or were put to death.
And then some more rational
people like, hey, yeah,
let's try to prevent that happening
again. I look at the city, God,
this is amazing.
You can see all the way to the other
city because there's no cities left. Um,
anyways. Um, so the constitution
is the answer to, that's really,
I know you don't see a lot about
Germany other than 1933 to 1945 or the,
she'll shit about, you
know, World War One,
but they don't show about the steps
that they took afterwards to ensure that
this wasn't going to happen again.
Uh,
I'm sure there's a nice book on it that
I could sit down and read if I wasn't
such a moron.
And he was denying support of that regime
is part of the constitutions inherent
character. I agree with that. The
problem, it doesn't change anything.
It's symbolism. We can now point at
our laws and tell other countries,
see we learned and what
do the Neo Nazis do?
They use fucking code,
which is not forbid,
such as 88,
I guess that means Heil
Hitler or H K N K R Z shirts,
which in German is recognize
is saying Hakan crudes,
which equals swastika. I swear
to God, those fuckers parody,
the run DMC logo with
Hkn Space K R Z shirts.
I had no idea.
Wow,
thanks for the podcast.
They keep me laughing during exams.
Looking forward to your German European
tour, you freckled con, you know,
that's gotta be the fascinating Shit
I've heard about Germany since, you know,
the same shit that they
show a zillion times on, um,
on the history channel. I mean, obviously
you've got to show that. So, you know,
hopefully that never happens again.
Um,
but they should probably shine a light
on this to know that that is going down.
I don't know. It's hard, man. I,
I believe looked like the Nazis Xix dick
kind of like a fucking think I used to
do a bit on this.
They're kind of like a band that had a
bunch of hits like fucking 40 years ago
and now they're coming back and it's just,
you know, there's no original members.
They don't have the magic. Any wishes it's
over. It's over. It's, it's uh, you know,
it's like, uh, you know, some,
some bands it's just their name
becomes toxic after awhile.
Okay.
You know,
although sometimes it's so bad that they
come back and people love him again.
I don't know,
it's probably a bad analogy,
but that's pretty frightening
that that shit's going down,
that people still like,
you know,
I dunno, I, I've never really been
to a Holocaust museum. It's just, I,
I just don't think I could handle it.
You know,
knowing that people are capable
of that level of fucking,
even just literally separating,
you know,
it shouldn't slavery that shit at the
board to separate parents from their
children to sit there and fucking do that.
I don't,
I don't give anybody a pass.
Even the fucking kid down
there like, this is my job.
Quit your fucking job.
I'm not fucking doing this.
When do you,
when is that Kid's screaming,
crying voice going to leave your
fucking head for the rest of your life?
Oh my God. Especially not having a kid
and no one like how much they need.
Like my daughter just came in,
she was like wine and all that.
For whatever reason, she wanted to
hug me, you know? I don't know why,
but they need just to take that away
from a kid that just, it's fucking,
you don't always some, I
dunno this getting, you know,
there's gotta be another
way. All right. Anyways, uh,
you sent my brother to the hospital.
The fuck are you talking about?
Can I legally read this without getting
all right?
Hey Billy Bro. Killer. My brother
and I went to your show early,
your early show in Minneapolis a couple
of weeks ago. And as we were leaving,
he was complaining about his back and
shoulder hurting being the Douche. I am.
I assumed he was whining
about the uncomfortable seat.
So the next few days he started coughing
and hearing a rattle in his chest. Yeah.
Okay. Well go to the doctor. He went
to the doc and as we were cautioned,
it turns out at some
point during your set,
his right lung made like the
Falcons and Superbowl 51 collapsed.
Well that's not from laughing. That was
like, you know, you went there. Yeah.
This is probably everything he
did up until that point. Um,
he spent,
I would love to take credit for any
jokes being funny enough to make some of
these lung collapse, but I
think your, uh, thank uh, uh,
yeah, you're looking at the ass
end of the problem there, but he,
he spent the next six days in the hospital
and had to get a tube stuck through
his rib cage, like Carl weathers
deaths, the death scene in Predator.
Then they hooked that
shit up to a dust buster,
sucked out the air that was outside
of his lung and sold the whole shut.
That's fascinating. He finally got
out of the hospital and is doing fine,
but I just thought you'd appreciate
knowing you're at the level where your
comedy,
because someone's Oregon to explode like
the God damn deathstar keep this up.
You'd be well on your way to fixing
the overpopulation problem anyways.
Can't wait for you to get come back to
Minnesota so he can finish the job and
get his left lung. Hope all is
well with the family. Thinks. Ah,
glad you guys came out and are glad
your brother's doing all right. Um,
all right. I think that's the, uh,
I think that's the podcast here,
uh, for this week. Um, all right. I think
there was a Formula One race today, ag.
I'm taping this Sunday night.
I got to a sit down and watch that,
but I got so much shit to do.
Um,
is that it is, do I
have anything? Oh yeah.
This weekend I'm going to be with
Nate Kraig and Houston. All right.
Houston, Texas. In July
as a bald, redheaded male.
And then I'm going to be in Dallas.
I don't know how many shows him fucking
do it. Yeah. Let me check it out here.
All right,
so here's the deal.
Thursday I got a show at
revention music center in Texas.
Friday I have a show at prevention
music center in Houston,
Texas. There's still tickets
to Thursday, Friday sold out.
And then I got two shows in,
uh,
the pavilion
up in Dallas at the Toyota music factory.
Um,
also I added a show right before
the rough and rowdy in Rochester,
New York, right outside of Buffalo,
which I haven't been to in a Zillion,
um,
Rochester,
former home of the Rochester royals that
then became the Cincinnati royals than
the Kansas City Slash Omaha kings.
Then the Kansas City kings and then
the Sacramento Kings. Hey Bill,
why would they,
Kansas City and Omar King spoke cause
they used to split their home games
between both those cities.
Seeing which town gave a fuck more.
Kansas City didn't have any
college football. Omaha did. Well,
I guess it's in Lincoln, Nebraska,
right? Where is university? Nebraska.
I only went to a fucking game out there.
I always forget where it had said. Um,
and then he became the sacrament of kinks.
I'm into that shit.
I'm going to pass tissues. You want to
hear a couple of cool ones? All right.
Here's a good one.
Kansas City Scouts,
NHL team moved to Colorado,
became the Colorado Rockies
and then moved to New Jersey,
became the New Jersey devils. Okay.
I can't do all your homework for you,
but I can do some of it. All right.
The original Washington senators,
1901 to 1960 they left and became the
Minnesota twins and then the senators came
back briefly in Washington,
almost like they retained the name like
the Cleveland browns and there was a
second incarnation of the
fucking Washington senators
and they also failed and
then they moved to Texas and
became the Texas Rangers.
All right.
You want to hear some more?
What else do I got? All right. The New
York Yankees, who were they originally?
The Baltimore Orioles.
1901 to 1902 then they became
the New York islanders,
1903 to 1912 then they
became the New York Yankees,
1913 to present,
not the Baltimore Oil Orioles.
I knew they were the
old Saint Louis Browns,
but I didn't realize they were the first.
They were the Milwaukee brewers in 1901
than they were then Saint Louis browns
1902 to 1953 and from 1954 till
now they became the Orioles.
All right. That's it can, I don't want
to talk to you guys anymore about this.
What the Oakland A's, is that, is that,
is that what you were asking about where
they were the Philadelphia athletics in
1901 to 1954 than the Kansas
City athletics to 1955 in
1967 and then they will,
the became the Oakland A's 1968 to 1986
and then the oath and Oakland athletics
in 1987 to present. I don't know what
that means as far as I'm concerned.
They've been the Oakland A's or the
athletics and 68 but that's what this
fucking thing said to me.
You know, and you know, I
learned about all of this shit.
A lot of teams have passed through Kansas
City, started there, gone through there,
and then that they just fucking,
you know, Kansas City Scouts,
Kansas City kings,
Kansas City athletics,
if had a lot of people come and go,
you know,
and there's only one solution that
I can think of. There's a lot of,
and Kansas City. All right, go fuck
yourselves. I'll talk to you on Thursday.